[Musique]
bonsoir 8 millions de détritus jetés
dans les mers et océans chaque jour et
la plaque de déchets plastique du
pacifique nord qui s'étend sur 2700 km
soit deux fois la distance ex porto un
cachalot a été retrouvé mort en
indonésie
son estomac contenait 115 gobelet 25
sacs quatre bouteilles
quatre tombes et des milliers de petits
morceaux
le tout en plastique un français produit
en moyenne 1 kg de déchets par jour
et le traitement de ces déchets
représentent 3% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre vous savez ces gaz qui
ont la particularité d'absorber le
rayonnement infrarouge produit par la
terre et qui seraient responsables du
réchauffement climatique
déprimant n'est ce pas oui non mais
alors ne comptez pas sur moi pour vous
plomber le moral je ne suis pas là pour
ça parce que constater c'est bien mais
agir c'est mieux et ces données sont une
véritable opportunité d'action dans la
vie on a le choix
voir le verre à moitié plein ou à moitié
vide
bon autant vous dire que moi j'ai essayé
les deux et j'ai commencé par le ver
vide
il est moins lourd mais bon bain comme
des vides il se passe pas grand chose
alors on regarde en espérant voir
quelque chose mais du coup au moral
ce qu'on voudrait le voir plein
ah j'étais doué j'avais cette capacité à
voir les problèmes partout à les mettre
au premier plan et derrière de me
plaindre
j'aurais pu est diplômé d'un master en
lamentations professionnels
et oui car se lamenter est un art mais
pas un art de vivre
et puis un jour je me suis sentie aussi
vite que le vert j'ai pris le temps
d'observer ma vie et j'ai constaté
l'ennui était récurrent surtout sur le
plan professionnel
après des études paramédicales et un
poste de préparatrice en pharmacie
cet univers ne correspondait plus du
tout aux valeurs que mon coeur
ressentait j'avais envie de vibrer me
sentir exister et d'agir pour l'humanité
alors oui me direz vous en soignant les
gens je leur faisais du bien mais
bonjour situe le contexte je n'étais que
celle qui délivrait les médicaments que
le médecins prescrivaient
cela ne me suffisait pas je voulais agir
autrement et j'ai toujours trouvé que la
médecine conventionnelle s'attardait
plus ce sont les symptômes que sur la
cause des problèmes
et voilà ce que je voulais moi c'était
agir sur la cause des problèmes
j'ai commencé à m'ouvrir à modifier mon
schéma de pensée pour voir le verre à
moitié plein et ma vie a radicalement
changé tout dans ma vie a changé
j'ai cessé de me plaindre et j'ai vu les
opportunités dans les obstacles
j'ai cessé de me lamenter et je suis
passé à l'action
parce qu'elle est là la clé passer à
l'action si tu fais rien il se passera
rien je me suis souvent plainte de ne
jamais réaliser mes rêves
aujourd'hui c'est un objectif
fondamental dans ma vie j'ai réalisé mon
premier rêve à 25 ans l'expatriation en
afrique
j'ai quitté mon boulot lâché mon appart
fait mes valises et je suis parti six
mois dans une pouponnière m'occuper des
enfants abandonnés
cette expérience a transformé ma vie
j'ai appris à vivre avec rien à me laver
les cheveux à l'eau froide avec un tuyau
quand il y avait de l'eau à vivre sans
frigo sans électricité à faire tout ça
sous 40° en compagnie des moustiques et
des cafards et vous savez quoi
et ben j'étais bien
c'est ça la magie de l'afrique là bas
avec rien ils ont l'essentiel le sourire
le reflet de leur âme
à mon retour en france j'ai été
métamorphosée et scandalisée je voyais
tous ces français avec tout parfois trop
mais sans l'essentiel sans ce sourire
ces gens qui comble un vide intérieur
par une opulence matériel elle était là
ma mission
parce que je l'avais vécu je voulais que
les gens comprennent que le bonheur
n'est pas dans le matérialisme
à mon retour j'avais plus de travail
j'aime pas trop quoi faire alors j'ai
profité de cette période pour analyser
le monde et faire une grande
introspection
en afrique il n'ya pas cette
consommation à outrance il réutilise
tout et développe de fait énormément
leur potentiel créatif
je revois ce petit enfant courir après
un pneu usagé qu'il faisait rouler et je
me revois avec une amie au pied d'une
cabane en paille en train de boire le
thé qui chauffait sur du crottin de
vache l'afrique m'a donné le goût du peu
et de l'essentiel
elle était là ma vie dans cet accord et
ce respect envers la planète envers la
nature et tout ce qu'elle m'offrait j'ai
aujourd'hui beaucoup de bienveillance et
de gratitude envers la vie sous toutes
ses formes et être écolo végétarienne
minimaliste et avec vous ce soir me rend
plus heureuse que jamais un jour j'ai lu
une phrase de gandhi vous savez le petit
homme moustachu à lunettes
elle disait soyez le changement que vous
voulez voir dans le monde
j'en ai fait mon leitmotiv j'ai compris
qu'il fallait se responsabiliser au
départ quand j'ai réalisé tout ça
lors de mon voyage je me suis dit
punaise mais tu es seul face à 99% de la
population
et puis tu te rends compte que d'une
part bon oui ok tu es fou et à la limite
c'est pas grave ce qui fait son charme
et qu'ensuite une vraie communauté de
fou comme doit existe et là la tuer
rassurer dans la vie il faut s'entourer
des gens qui nous font du bien et qui
partagent des valeurs communes
je m'inspire beaucoup de gens inspirants
je vous ai cités gandhi mais il n'est
pas le seul
j'aime aussi beaucoup la pensée de
churchill qui disait prenez le
changement par la main avant qu'il ne
vous prennent par la gorge ou encore
pierre rabhi qui disait que si chacun de
nous se faisait un peu avec le peu qu'il
peut alors on ferait beaucoup il n'y a
pas de petites actions
il n'y a que des grandes intentions nous
sommes jeunes et le monde de demain nous
appartient préservons le
alors moi écolo est engagé je me suis
demandé comment à ma manière
avec mes compétences je pouvait agir sur
la cause du problème il n'est plus
possible de continuer à polluer autant
j'avais une passion la couture et j'ai
décidé d'allier cette passion aux
valeurs qui me portait depuis je
remplace les objets en plastique et en
papier jetables par des objets en tissu
que je fabrique moi-même c'est ma
contribution pour l'environnement qui me
permet de sortir que quatre poubelles à
l'année en parallèle je trie les déchets
recyclables et je fais le compost c'est
possible et c'est plus simple que vous
le pensez ce que je veux dire c'est que
chacun de nous à la possibilité d'agir
en fonction de ses préférences et sans
contrainte mettre sa peau de banane dans
la poubelle ou dans le bac à compost ça
prend le même temps mettre son coton à
démaquiller dans la poubelle ou dans le
bac à linge ça prend le même temps
tout est question d'habitude 21 jours
c'est le temps nécessaire pour changer
une habitude c'est à dire que pendant 21
jours vous allez devoir y penser avant
que cela ne devienne évident vous allez
penser à ramasser les déchets et après
j'avais pensé à ne plus en produire tout
du moins à en produire moi je sais que
vous êtes prêt et je vous y encourage
je suis toujours enjoué à l'idée de
parler de l'écologie parce que j'ai
l'intimé conviction que nous devons
faire évoluer le monde sur ce terrain là
et en parler sensibiliser les gens à ça
c'est une autre de mes missions
on a là un objectif à atteindre pour
demain on n'a pas le temps de pleurer
faisons de demain un monde écologique y
croire c'est le penser et le penser
c'est y arriver aujourd'hui je pense que
pour accomplir quelque chose dans sa vie
il faut en être convaincu et moi je suis
ici devant vous et je suis convaincu que
vous pouvez m'aider à contribuer à une
planète plus saine et moins polluer
chaque geste chaque déchets ramassés
chaque emballage n'en achetez fera de
vous un acteur de l'écologie est un
contributeur au meilleur monde de demain
comme le disait si justement margaret
mid anthropologue américaine ne doutez
jamais qu'un petit groupe de personnes
puissent changer le monde
en fait c'est toujours ainsi que le
monde a changé
alors ne doutez pas de vous ne doutez
pas de nous c'est facile c'est possible
ça te prend 21 jours pour s'y faire pour
des années de sérénité derrière merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]